what's going on guys this is rob and uh
it's cold outside and i'm sore from
working out anyway
one of the big questions a lot of you
guys been asking at least my thoughts on
it anyway and one of the big theories
going on out there is that mephisto was
going to appear in spider-man no way
home a lot of people are using the scene
from the trailer where doctor strange
and spider-man are at the statue of
liberty and that in the original trailer
doctor strange said i can't stop them
and then uh in the newer trailer dr
strange says i can't stop him so
basically referring to a guy as opposed
to a group of people and the people are
saying that basically looks like the
arrival of mephisto and people are using
the idea of the history between mephisto
and spiderman as a way to indicate
that's actually the case i mean i get
that you guys want to see mephisto in
the mcu that's not how mephisto would
appear mephisto would not show up in the
mcu by coming through a giant portal
that opened over the statue of liberty
and just being like hello everybody on
earth i'm mephisto and you're all [ __ ]
that's not what mephisto would do
instead
mephisto would visit peter parker at his
most vulnerable assuming peter was the
person that mephisto was after which
would likely be the case given the
history between like spider-man one more
day and like what looks to be the plot
of spider-man no way home so again you
know it's it's a little a little
interesting there insofar as mephisto
being a possibility at the end of the
day though i just don't see it happening
will mephisto ever appear in the mcu i
don't know uh maybe i imagine if the
marvel cinematic universe did not
actually have any plans for mephisto to
appear they probably do now if for no
other reason than just the fact that
like we all want to see it so they're
probably trying to find some way to work
him in if he would appear i could see it
being in doctor strange too maybe some
kind of a cameo or something along those
lines having said that
what do i think is going on in that
scene in spider-man no way home
i think it's kane the conqueror more so
than that i think it's king's entire
invading force so one of the things to
keep in mind when it comes to king the
conqueror based on what we saw in loki
and all that kind of stuff is kang
originates on earth it's different
earths and different alternate realities
but it's always earth and it's always
from the future of that earth in the
comics is something like the 30th
century or something along those lines
maybe the 31st but in the in the loki
series all fingers point to the idea
that at a future point in time king the
conqueror will appear now in mobile
comics there's never really been an
instance where king has wiped out an
entire universe uh there have been
instances when he's changed the history
of universes and in fact that's actually
going on in the comics right now and the
kang the conqueror limited series he's
actually changing his own history so we
can kind of see maybe that playing out
in some way in the marvel cinematic
universe but i think that kang showing
up here on earth makes the most logical
sense and the reason why is because one
earth is home to some of the most
powerful beings in the entirety of
marvel comics and seemingly in the
marvel cinematic universe the only
exceptions that i can really think of
are people like maybe thanos or like the
celestials or carol danvers but outside
of the celestials and possibly whatever
eternals may exist out there based on
you know our indication from star fox
and pip the troll at the end of the
eternals film earth still seems to have
some of the heaviest hitters now if the
marvel cinematic universe grabs mama
comics and reels it over well then
that's just definitively the case right
earth has reality warpers right we've
got universe-wide telepaths we've got
telekinetics that can move planets earth
has all kinds of crazy powerful beings
in the marvel cinematic universe power
doesn't really exist on that scale i
think it might at a future point in time
but i think for right now earth is still
a pretty powerful place and if king the
conqueror really does exist or hail from
earth then earth would be the first
place to conquer because he could
basically ensure his own existence more
so than that it would be a kind of
maximum security storyline type
situation for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with that maximum security
was a story that was written above a
comics where basically earth was turned
into a prison planet and ron and the
accuser was the warden at that point in
time ron is dead and i doubt he would be
the warden in this particular situation
but basically earth was turned into a
prison planet and the reason why is
because the cree and the scroll of
course as most of you guys know either
from comics or from the movies or doing
your own reading have been waging war
against each other for millions of years
and because of how powerful people on
earth were that if a race were able to
subjugate earth and force the citizens
of earth to work in their service while
they may or may not be able to conquer
the universe depending on who they have
working for them they could certainly
put a dent in conquering the various
races and empires that exist out there
the badoon the shiar the cree or the
scrolls any number of those guys and so
having kane the conquerors show up on
earth and then immediately conquer it
and then basically turn it into a planet
that he rules with absolute authority
would possibly allow him to subjugate
the earth's populace maybe the avengers
or whoever and potentially even spread
outward from there now say that's
actually the case and doctor strange and
spider-man are standing there and the
portals opening and king the conquerors
entire invasion fleet so not just him
but like ships are all just descending
down with futuristic technology the
humanity in the 21st century is woefully
ill-equipped to stand against there'd
really be nothing doctor strange and
spider-man could do doctor strange is
powerful but it doesn't really look like
there'd be a whole lot he could do in
that situation and so if that's the case
say that for example they get teleported
away right they get removed from that
situation spider-man and doctor strange
now we can interpret that a couple
different ways and this is where i want
to pitch this idea to you because i want
to see how you all feel about this right
say for example the portals opening up
king's entire invading fleet is coming
in and say that doctor strange and peter
like okay we have to do something about
this and then they can't and the reason
why they can't is because loki teleports
in behind them and it's like there's
nothing you can do here i mean if you
fight you will die i've seen it happen
across all these universes where the
avengers across countless worlds try to
defeat kang and they all fall to the
power of king to conquer so loki whisks
them away right loki takes them away
because as we know from the conclusion
of loki when he was there and he saw
kane the conqueror replaced himself with
the statue of the of the the timekeepers
and so on and so forth the kang is very
nefarious he's a villain that loki is
likely trying to do what he can to save
what he can possibly even work directly
against kang himself to stop him from
coming to power or at least consolidate
some kind of a military or some kind of
a force that can oppose kang it would
make perfect sense that his first
thought would be the people of my home
universe right the people back in my
world thor's out in space we know that
from the ending of guardians of the
galaxy too maybe loki knows maybe loki
doesn't but regardless if loki shows up
at like the 11th hour at that moment
right when kang is arriving and he's
like oh my god i'm too late there's
nothing i can do here but then he sees
doctor strange and peter then he's like
whatever that's better than nothing so
he snatches them up takes them away and
then from there it splits off into their
respective stories right that loki
basically tells dr strange and peter
parker here's everything that's going on
i'm trying to solve it for my end here's
what i'm doing you got to try to solve
it for your end you go do your own thing
and that goes into the plot of doctor
strange multiverse of madness and then
you have the story of loki that
continues on in loki season 2 and then
concludes an ant-man 3 quantomania not
gonna lie to you guys i'd be
disappointed if that was the case right
i said that in a podcast that i was in
recently with josh over denim nerds and
i was like there's no way that they are
going to end the the
the whole kane saga
in ant-man three like hey everybody king
the conqueror is invading earth and he's
like a multiversal threat and he wants
to just conquer all of reality but the
only one that can stop him is a guy who
burgles like it's just it just it
doesn't work
it just doesn't work it seems goofy so
it would have to go in like some kind of
like a new avengers film or some kind of
coming together film or something along
those lines but certainly not ant-man 3
quantum mania it just it just it just
doesn't
it just doesn't feel right you know what
i mean like i mean it's like yeah i mean
i guess but i mean
avengers man like do it in an avengers
movie right just just give it that where
everybody comes together and everything
pops off but let me know what you guys
think about that right i think that's a
very strong possibility because i was
talking to my social media guy tony on
the way up here to fort collins and he
made a really good point he was like
they need to get to work on this whole
okay and the conqueror thing man because
people want to see him right he gets
basically teased at the end of loki when
he who remains a mortis dies and he's
like okay well you guys killed me now
you guys are really screwed because now
you guys are going to have to deal with
kang uh
good luck
and just kind of goes forward from there
so it's like okay like like because we
haven't seen hide nor hair of anything
to do with kane the conqueror ever since
and so it's like okay give us something
and i think a great way to bring kang in
is at the end of spider-man no way home
when what i imagine to be is going to be
a lot of pain and suffering because a
lot of you guys are pointing to the idea
that like maybe mj or aunt may might die
and then like at the end of all all that
stuff then it's like no peter parker the
struggle is just starting like this this
like lost pain and suffering no no it's
just beginning like you thought thanos
was bad he's got nothing on kane to
conquer i think that would be a great
concept i think it'd be a great idea but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section i'm really really
curious do you guys think this plot this
this theme would work right you
basically start off with kang
essentially launching an invasion
against earth in the marvel cinematic
universe at the end of spider-man no way
home loki appears he tells doctor
strange and peter there's nothing you
can do here if you stay you will die you
have to come with me and so in effect
they have to leave everybody behind
right the avengers as we know them now
are left behind wanda is presumably
either out in the universe or in the
multiverse herself so she's not directly
affected by it uh thor is in space so
that explains why thor wouldn't know
what was going on on earth and why he
wouldn't really be part and parcel to it
so that's his character story arc when
it's just like oh my god like what's
going on here right leon why is why is
earth conquered you know or something
along those lines right then it
continues on into doctor strange
multiverse of madness where it's
basically like three parts of the same
story the doctor strange covers his part
of the story which may or may not deal
with king directly we may even see
instances where he comes across
universes or he and peter do where like
king has already conquered that universe
or we see what it looks like after kane
conquers the universe and basically
leaves it in ruins or the very least
that earth something along those lines
we also get that story told from the
perspective of loki in loki season 2
when he's doing his thing which is
basically happening at the exact same
time as doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness and then we get ant-man 3
quantum mania which looks like it
actually deals directly with kang
himself whereas doctor strange and loki
are kind of beating around the bush and
dealing a little bit with kang but more
on like the side skirmishes then ant-man
3 is king head on and then it ends
however it is that it ends but let me
know what you guys think about that i'm
really curious because i feel like
there's a strong possibility this could
be the case it sounds like something the
mcu would do right a more condensed
version of what we saw in the infinity
saga where instead of getting like
glimpses of the infinity stones here and
glimpses of the infinity stones there
and some post-credit scene where thanos
grabs a gauntlet and says fine i'll do
it myself for something on those lines
that it's a more condensed version of
that but we see more of those threads
across differing projects that are
happening in the marvel cinematic
universe but let me know what you guys
think thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace